oh hi
it is the dead of winter and for some
reason every game coming out
this week has to do with dead things
whether that is
shambling zombies or revolting demons or
japanese schoolgirls who are dead here
is the rundown of this week's new
video games first up is dmc
devil may cry from capcom you might
remember the devil may cry series about
dante a demon hunter who goes into the
bowels of hell and slays every gross
pulsating thing that he can find
this new version is a little bit
different it's actually not developed in
japan it's developed by
ninja theory the uk developer that
created heavenly sword and
enslaved journey to the west the devil
make prize series has always been
praised for its amazing graphic
stylish action really really tight
combat but
it's always been really difficult devil
may cry from ninja theory is
supposed to be a little bit more
accessible it's aimed at a wider
audience
dante has been redesigned to be a
younger hipper
sort of emoji stereotypical character
but
look it's still very flashy it's still
very stylized
still interesting to watch and it's just
less demanding
on the player now maybe you hate this
but
capcom doesn't really have any options
anymore they've they've
got to make this series appealing to
a wider audience if they want to keep
selling copies of devil may cry games so
devil may cry fans look at it with an
open mind it's probably going to be
pretty awesome
even if it's not quite the devil may cry
you used to enjoy
devil may cry is coming out on january
15th for xbox 360 and playstation 3.
also coming on january 15th is siren the
classic
2003 playstation 2 game has been touched
up
and is being re-released on the
playstation 3 as a download
this is a survival horror game but it's
a more classically japanese one it is
set in the small japanese town of hanuda
where shibito which just pretty much
means dead people
are wandering around the town and you've
got to
not get killed by them now how do you do
that besides
avoiding them and trying not to get
bitten or whatever it is they do to you
you have a move called sight jacking you
as the main character can see through
the
eyes of the shibito if you can get close
enough to them as they kind of
shamble around town now looking through
their eyes will give you clues as to
where you should go
and it'll also let you know what their
movement patterns are
or where they are in any given instance
and that's what you've got to do to
survive in this
very creepy very understated game siren
is a bit of a cult classic it didn't do
that well when it first came out so
hopefully this new downloadable release
will give this forgotten title a new
lease on life
finally if you're one of the few
remaining people still playing the sony
psp
corps party book of shadows is coming
out on playstation network as a
downloadable game
for psp that can also be played on the
playstation vita
the corpse party series started its life
as a sort of fan-made low-budget
pc gaming series in japan it's survival
horror
but with a cartoony twist you are a
group of japanese school girls who uh
dabbled in some magic that they probably
shouldn't have and now find themselves
in a very haunted
and very dangerous school building which
many people have been transported to
and died and so now what you're trying
to do is
a not die then b find the corpses of a
whole lot of people in this school who
have perished there before
players of the first corpse party found
it to be a very charming funny kind of
freaky but still really interesting game
and the sequel is going to give them
more of what they loved it's got
various chapters each of which presents
a different little mini story
within the corpse party universe corpse
party book of shadows will also be
available on january 15th for the price
of
20 so as you can see video game
publishers
are not slowing down even though it's
just the beginning of the year they are
already releasing many new games every
week so keep watching game life and we
will keep telling you
what to spend your money on